[Music]
our question
comes from sarah in kentucky and like i
promise you all this is a
real good one she says when my husband
and i got engaged he got a statement in
the mail stating
that he had 180 000
in student loan debt he was completely
unaware of the amount of debt
he had in his name he got his teaching
degree on a 50
baseball scholarship our whole married
lives his parent
promised us that they would pay off the
loans and they would never
ever be our responsibility now
with their desire to retire soon this is
where it gets good
their tune is starting to change my
husband and i are on babysit number two
and are on track to be debt free by
december 2021
so dave my question is do we continue to
focus on our debt
and progress through the baby steps or
do we take on these
other loans as well how do you suggest
we proceed
well i'm like down the middle here
i i think there's a serious conversation
that needs to be had here
uh with the parents but then on the flip
side it's also if you and your husband
are in a financial position to at least
help uh your parents i think you should
if this was me
i'm talking to mom i'm talking to dad
saying hey i get it you want to retire
soon but
you told us that we're not responsible
for it
but i still do have some some point of
obligation to it because it is my
education that
um it is costing this much but i would
really have a conversation with my
parents because you could have told us
this a while ago and it would not be 180
000
today sarah i'm calling bullcrap uh
oh your husband gets a
thing in the mail right after you're
engaged saying he has
a 180 000 student loan in his name which
means he signed the freaking papers
and he had no idea bullcrap
of course he knew of course he knew
he's freaking lying
he's the biggest space cadet on the
planet how do you go 200 grand in debt
and go oops
i didn't know i had no idea i was
playing baseball
come on seriously unbelievable
now that his mom and dad promised to pay
it so he didn't pay attention
well that's fairly likely yeah but if
he's going to play the dumb jock card
i'm calling bull
wow i mean he knew what was going on
here yeah he got a good point dave
and so here's the deal uh you just got
engaged and as the new daughter-in-law
you walk in there with muddy boots in
their kitchen and you start throwing
your weight around demanding they keep
their word
that's not gonna go over not at all
so your husband
who apparently has no idea what's going
on here
needs to step up and deal with his
parents he has
a 180 000 loan in his name you married
him you have 180 000
in debt yep and that's the legal facts
if mom and dad choose to keep their word
and help
that is wonderful but you have a hundred
and eighty thousand dollars in debt you
married a guy
that had 180 000 in debt you guys knew
this you're gonna end up paying it if
they don't
because it's legally your obligation and
he knew this was going on
yeah bull i told you this was gonna be
good
[Laughter]
i was trying to beat well i mean if it's
18 000 in debt and he thought he was on
a baseball scholarship and he signed a
couple piece of paper not half watching
when he was an
18 year old kid i believe that but 180
grand you don't accidentally fall into
that and go oh no i do
that's just bull and i would love to
know where did he go to school to where
fifty percent is about 80 grand yeah
that's a lot of
money yeah i mean it's probably about
120
because that's probably including the
interest and stuff well i don't know how
long i don't know how
how many people have been married i
don't know how old